foreign
with the first pick in the 2003 NBA
Draft
the Cleveland Cavaliers select LeBron
James
[Applause]
there he is with his mom Gloria
glorious sacrificed a lot gave birth to
LeBron when she was 16.
on their own in 19 living on assistance
food stamps and here they are just a
short time later
100 million dollars in contract
endorsements in basketball and LeBron
James
makes a great American story Mike Banks
LeBron this was a moment years in the
making and even though you knew you were
going to be the top pick in the draft
you said you weren't sure how you'd feel
when David Stern actually called your
name so I have to ask you what was the
moment like I was great you know this is
a long time dream to finally accomplish
this and it finally shows that the hard
work has finally paid off for me and a
lot lies ahead you will most certainly
be the most scrutinized rookie in the
history of the NBA what will make a
successful season by your definition in
the rookie year you know seeing our team
get better every day I think that's
going to be the biggest accomplishment
for us because last year we went pretty
good but if I feel like we get better
every day as a team that's gonna be my
biggest goal this year there has been
some talk that they might want to play
at the point guard what do you think I
think I'll be ready for it you know for
anything that co-stars need me to do for
my team to win I think I'll be happy
about it you threw out to Carmelo
Anthony
of the Year let's compete why will you
win that contest you know I think you
know I'm not sure I'm going to win the
contest I just think that I'm just going
to try to get my teammates better you
know I'm not looking for individual
things I'm all about the team
the team wears this jersey on the road
LeBron
here it is
enjoy it
the cash fans make at home